madame la présidente madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales madame la rapporteur générale
Mesdames et Messieurs les rapporteurs
mesdames et messieurs les
députés nous nous retrouvons à nouveau
dans une situation que nous connaissons
toutes et tous et qui ne surprendra
personne une position de principe des
groupes d'opposition qui ne souhait pas
bâtir des majorités sur les textes
financiers queles que soient les
concertations menées et le contenu du
projet de
loi des délais constitutionnels que nous
savons contraints et qui ont encore été
réduits par la multiplication des
motions de censure et un texte le projet
de loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale dont notre pays a besoin dont
nos concitoyens ont besoin ce PLFSS est
ambitieux 640 milliards d'euros
d'investissement pour
2024 640 milliards d'euros pour notre
pour les familles pour l'autonomie de
nos aînés et des personnes en situation
de handicap pour nos retraites 640
milliards d'euros qui tomberaiit si vous
rejetiez cette deuxème partie du PLFSS
elle nous permet de répondre à des
enjeux majeurs renforcer la lutte contre
la fraude faire évoluer les cotisations
sociales des travailleurs indépendants
pour améliorer leur retraite prendre des
mesures importantes pour les
agriculteurs pour les jeunes des lycées
prof
c'est une partie qui a été enrichie par
des amendements de la majorité comme des
oppositions en première lecture dans
cette assemblée et par des amendements
du Sénat mesdames et messieurs les
députés le projet de loit de financement
de la sécurité sociale et le cœur même
de notre modèle social il rassemble et
protège les Français nous ne pouvons pas
prendre le risque de les en privé aussi
sur le fondement de l'article 49 alinéa
3 de la Constitution j'engage la
responsabilité de mon gouvernement sur
la deuxème partie du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2024 je vous
remercie merci beaucoup madame la
Première
ministre l'Assemblée nationale prend
acte de l'engagement de la
responsabilité du gouvernement
conformément aux dispositions de
l'article 49 alinéa 3 de la Constitution
le texte sur lequel la première ministre
engage la responsabilité du gouvernement
sera annexé au compte-rendu de la
présente séance en application de
l'article 155 alinéa 1er du règlement le
débat sur ce texte est immédiatement
suspendu ce texte sera considéré comme
adopté sauf si une motion de censure
déposée avant demain 18h47 est voté dans
les mêmes conditions dans les conditions
prévu à l'article 49 de la Constitution
dans l'hypothèse où une motion de
censure serait déposée la Conférence des
Présidents fixera la date et les
modalités de sa discussion la séance est
suspendue je vous
remercie